[Musique]
la commission c'est donc réuni cet
après-midi à voter tous les amendements
que propose et les rapporteurs vous le
savez chaque année au projet de loi de
financement de la sécurité sociale du
mois de novembre nous mettions un
amendement relatif à la branche
vieillesse pour avoir un objectif
d'équilibre du régime en 2030 toujours
refusé par le gouvernement mais cette
année le gouvernement a présenté un
projet de loi de finance rectificatif de
la sécurité sociale qui donc reprend
grosso modo les ce que demandait le
Sénat chaque année néanmoins il leur
reprend de façon partielle le texte qui
arrive au Sénat est déjà quelque peu en
déficit parce que certains amendements
ont été votés à l'Assemblée nationale
donc notre ligne de crête en fait au
Sénat est assez réduite nous pensons que
il faut faire des propositions autour de
l'emploi des seniors avant de leur
imposer de travailler de façon
supplémentaire et puis qu'on puisse
travailler dans le meilleur condition
travailler plus mais travailler mieux
c'est la raison pour laquelle nous avons
fait des propositions ce qui concerne la
retraite progressive les personnes qui
sont en situation d'incapacité
permanente que l'on propose de ne pas
décaler dans cette réforme sur l'âge
pour les femmes nous avons voulu marquer
d'une part le fait que c'est une
retraite qui repose sur la solidarité
intergénérationnelle donc la natalité le
taux de natalité à son importance et
donc nous avons souhaité mettre une
surcote pour justement le bénéfice de
ces trimestres qui sont acquis lors
d'une maternité d'une adoption ou de
l'éducation d'un enfant nous avons un
temps qui n'est pas négligeable et qui
est important même par rapport au temps
de l'Assemblée nationale qui est
beaucoup plus important que le temps que
l'on s'accroche chaque année au PLFSS
donc je pense que tous les sénateurs
pourront s'exprimer et s'il y a pas de
volonté de blocage en effet on doit
pouvoir arriver au bout de ce texte ce
que je souhaite ardemment c'est qu'en
effet il y a un texte qui sort du Sénat
après tout le monde n'est pas d'accord
sur ce qui sortira mais c'est le jeu
démocratique